[موسيقى]
دبي بالنسبة لي تتحرك بسرعة ديناميكية ،
لكن الشيء المذهل هو أنه لا يوجد
يومان متماثلان في دبي ، هناك
دائمًا شيء ما يحدث ، اسمي
جيسيكا كاراتيه وأنا عارضة أزياء ومحسن
أعيش في منطقة رائعة هنا في
وسط مدينة دبي على قمة دبي
مول ، لذا لديّ دبي مول باعتباره الفناء الخلفي الخاص بي ، كما
تعلمون ، أحب شراء المزيد ، أنا واحد
من هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين سيمشون
في القاعة لساعات لأنه يوجد
كل
شيء هناك  مدينة داخل مدينة
[موسيقى]
يأتي الجميع إلى وسط مدينة دبي ،
لا يمكنك الهروب منها ،
اسمي هو هو تشون أنا فنانة
فيتنامية كورية ، دبي مول هو
المكان الرئيسي في وسط مدينة دبي ، أعني أن هذا هو
المكان الذي يأتي فيه الجميع إذا نظرت حولك
سترى أشخاصًا من كل مكان
سياحًا من جميع أنحاء العالم ،
كل هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين ورائي يصطفون
في طابور للذهاب إلى الجزء العلوي وهو
سطح المراقبة الموجود تقريبًا من
أعلى منصة مراقبة في العالم
عشت في وسط المدينة لمدة 10 سنوات  لكن
أنا ها  لم أفعل هذا أبدًا ، ما
أفعله عادةً هو الاقتراب ، وعادةً ما آخذ أصدقائي
إلى الجانب الآخر ، هناك شريط يسمى
الغلاف الجوي أعتقد أنه يجب علينا القيام بذلك ،
دعنا نذهب 88 89 90 إلى 95100 تظهر أذني
108 9 12 ونحن هنا  نحن في
الأجواء ، نحن في الطابق 120 الثالث ،
ألبرت خليفة مع هذا المنظر الرائع
لدبي والخليج العربي والشمس على
وشك أن تحدد
هذه هي الطريقة التي تعمل بها في دبي وأيضًا
إذا كنت في منطقة برج خليفة بوسط
المدينة فهذا هو المكان  تريد أن تكون مبتهجًا ،
فإن منظر غروب الشمس من برج
خليفة مذهل وإذا لم تكن قد
رأيت ذلك فعليك أن تشكرك كثيرًا